florida's hb one five five seven also  known as the don't say gay bill don't  say it don't you dare say it gay  gay gay the implication being that don't  say or gay  is in the bill and it's not we made this  one up it's a total fabrication we got  you are you sure it's something that is  completely made up you're doing it  doing what using your imagination peter  you didn't even read it i glanced at it  this is about transparency in education  and making sure that state employees  cannot infect children with whatever  their ideas are and then hide it from  the parents how was school i'm a lesbian  seems reasonable our goal as a company  is for this law to be repealed screw you  disney who me you're lying about what  the bill is read it read the charter  people well maybe we should just read it  that seems reasonable  i can't read